[Musica]
anche io sono responsabile
sono responsabile perché da 25 anni il
lavoro nella moda come design director
per importanti brand dell'abbigliamento
uno dei settori più inquinanti anzi
probabilmente il secondo settore più
inquinante del nostro pianeta
così tre anni fa ho deciso di cambiare
tutto nella mia vita di cambiare la mia
vita privata è la mia vita professionale
ma perché questo cambiamento così
importante così radicale perché vedevo
negli ultimi anni le aziende parlare di
sviluppo green verso l'agenda ono 2030
utilizzando parole come etica
sostenibilità cambiamento ma senza avere
effettivamente la cognizione di causa di
quello che loro stavano dicendo o
facendo il tempo passa e l'inquinamento
aumenta
basti pensare che quest'anno per la
prima volta l'anidride carbonica
presente nella nostra atmosfera ha
superato i 400 e 20 ppm avvicinandosi a
quella soglia psicologica stabilita
dagli scienziati di 450 che superando
questa soglia potrebbe significare che
il nostro pianeta non in grado più di
contenere l'aumento di un grado
centigrado e quindi con conseguenze che
potrebbero essere devastanti e
catastrofiche per il nostro pianeta il
settore moda o se oltre a essere
responsabile di aumento del co2 è anche
responsabile dell'utilizzo spropositato
dell'acqua di sostanze chimiche
pesticidi ma soprattutto un dato
allarmante è quello che vengono prodotti
centinaia milioni di capi che non
vengono neanche indossati utilizzati e
solo l'un per cento viene riciclato
io di fronte a
a questi dati non sono mai stato in
sensibile
anzi sentivo dentro sempre un qualcosa
di che mi diceva io devo cambiare e devo
cambiare quello che mi sta attorno
così ho iniziato a unire la mia passione
alla moda con la sensibilità che avevo
nei confronti dell'ambiente degli
animali e il dello spreco ma soprattutto
quella filosofia slow che mi appartiene
la quale dal mio punto di vista è
l'unica filosofia descrivere esattamente
il progresso green dove pone al centro
del progresso
l'uomo e l'ambiente così tre anni fa ha
deciso di realizzare una mia azienda ma
nell'azienda che non vendesse soltanto
un prodotto vendesse solo abbigliamento
ma che vendesse dei valori in base a un
proprio comportamento
infatti ho sempre pensato che l'azienda
è come una persona ha un comportamento
ha un'educazione ma soprattutto ha un
cuore e al centro di questo c'è il
design il design dal mio punto di vista
avrà una responsabilità fondamentale per
lo sviluppo perché dovrà coniugare
sempre di più l'armonia del bello con la
funzionalità con l'ambiente con le
persone
quindi il design di vien diventa un
qualcosa di più ampio da questo pensiero
ho realizzato sette principi per
descrivere il progresso green
il primo è il design deve essere etico e
responsabile infatti arriviamo da
decenni di un trionfo disarmante del
design estetico dove le aziende dovevano
colpire stupire il consumatore finale
poi non importa di come ci sono arrivato
ma l'importante era raggiungerli oggi
questo ciclo sta per finire inizia in
qualcosa di nuovo
iniziamo a parlare finalmente di un
design etico il quale pone al centro
però un aspetto fondamentale l'aspetto
morale
quindi bisogna sempre tenere in
considerazione l'aspetto estetico ma
quando si va a progettare bisogna
coniugare l'ambiente e le persone e
tutto ciò che lo circonda
un altro aspetto fondamentale del design
e quello che bisogna pensare e
realizzare prodotti di qualità che
abbiano un ciclo di vita più lungo
cercando di diminuire l'impatto negli
eco sistema valorizzando le diversità e
soprattutto quando si va a progettare
bisogna pensare al destino di
quell'oggetto l'ultimo aspetto che
compone il design è che stando
all'inizio di una catena del valore alla
grande responsabilità di coordinare
tutto il processo
solo così possiamo avere uno sviluppo
green salvaguardando l'idea finale con
l'oggetto finale
il secondo aspetto il secondo principio
è quello della scelta delle materie
prime di solito la scelta delle materie
prime viene fatta in base a due aspetti
il prezzo è l'estetica
oggi questo non va più bene fermo
restando e dando per scontato che chi
sceglie abbia le giuste competenze deve
avere la capacità e la sensibilità di
andare a verificare le aziende senza
fermarsi a una certificazione o un
documento al dovere di verificare se
quella fornitore è nella nostra linea
della brand value questo è fondamentale
perché nella mia esperienza ho visto che
aziende piccole che magari non avevano
la capacità economica di acquisire delle
certificazioni erano più se più
sostenibili rispetto a quelle grandi che
magari avevano una capacità economica
quindi non sto dicendo che la
certificazione è un qualcosa
insicuro anzi
mentale averla ma non deve essere
l'unico elemento di scelta
l'ultimo aspetto è quello che bisogna
considerare la provenienza delle materie
prime quindi capire dove sono state
fatte come sono state fatte
il terzo principio che è quello più a me
caro sono le filiere corte produttive
cosa vuol dire bollire mettere insieme
tante aziende a filiera sinergiche e
complementari e bio diverse tra di loro
creando dei veri propri distretti che
possono essere di natura locale
regionale e nazionale
solo attraverso questa strategia noi
possiamo abbattere in modo sostanziale
l'anidride carbonica evitando
spostamenti di merce da una parte
all'altra del mondo
inoltre avendo una filiera corta c'è la
possibilità di andare a verificare come
stanno lavorando i fornitori capire se
sono in linea
ovviamente il prezzo è più alto
però quella differenza di prezzo ci
viene restituita sotto altre forme
una salvaguardia dell'ambiente e
soprattutto anche una possibilità di
avere una qualità più alta il quarto
principio e il territorio
l'azienda non è un qualcosa di
scollegato al territorio è parte
integrante
questo è un principio importante tutto
ciò che viene preso dall'azienda deve
essere restituito al territorio
bisogna capire questo processo quindi
l'azienda ha il dovere e la
responsabilità di avere relazioni con
associazioni enti enti di categoria
scuole giovani per costruire qualcosa
nello stesso tempo ha il dovere di
salvaguardare il passaggio di know how
di generazione in generazione dando
lavoro
un altro aspetto fondamentale del
territorio è anche quello di conoscere
le aziende che lavorano all'interno del
territorio quindi andare a inserire
nelle
filiere aziende virtuose che investono
nell'innovazione
ma anche il design ha una grande
responsabilità alla grande
responsabilità per esempio nelle nostre
montagne dolomitiche
ci sono migliaia di pecore e ogni anno
vengono buttate via quintali di lana
perché ritenuto un rifiuto speciale
quindi costoso quindi spesso viene
sotterrato viene bruciato viene disperso
recando un danno importante l'ambiente
quindi grazie alla sensibilità di
allevatori locali
cosa è successo hanno iniziato a
raccogliere questa lana viene fornita a
un'azienda la quale la tratta la lava
crea tessuto magari questo tessuto non
ha la stessa qualità della lana che
viene prodotta dall altra parte del
mondo ma delle sue caratteristiche e qui
deve intervenire il design deve sapere
prendere quel tessuto e dagli quel
valore aggiunto attraverso
un'interpretazione del design stesso e
rimetterla nel mercato così creiamo
economia virtuosa economia buona
economia locale ridando valore i nostri
territori
ridando valore alle persone e ridando
valore al territorio
il quinto aspetto è la trasparenza le
aziende oggi devono raccontare e
raccontarsi e fondamentale senza questo
non esiste sostenibilità devono dire chi
sono come fanno e raccontare anche i
prodotti come sono stati fatti oggi
esistono tantissime tecnologie che lo
permettono
ma un passaggio che secondo me è
fondamentale e quello che l'etichetta
interna della composizione che è un
qualcosa sempre stato messo dentro e
nascosto deve essere tirata fuori deve
essere visibile e di e deve diventare da
un etichetta
così anonima ha un'etichetta parlante a
un'etichetta responsabile deve informare
i clienti di come è stato fatto
quell'oggetto per dargli in mano a chi
compra la possibilità di sapere il sesto
punto e l'educazione che un concetto
fondamentale deve essere educata
all'azienda ma deve essere educato anche
il consumatore
l'azienda deve essere educata perché
deve avere una onestà intellettuale non
deve raccontare bugie ma deve essere
onesta con se stessa e con il cliente ed
è un passaggio che sta succedendo in
questi anni che nessuno di voi sa è
attraverso l'agenda o no 2030 il
dodicesimo punto parla di produzione e
consumo responsabile
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che è tutta la
responsabilità non viene scaricata solo
sulle aziende come tutti noi pensiamo
ecc e diventiamo indifferenti ma noi e
voi avete la responsabilita
dell'acquisto quindi noi consumatori e
voi consumatori dovete essere educati
informati e sapere cosa comprare
perché se voi comprate bene e comprate
le aziende virtuose
noi aiutiamo l'ambiente aiutiamo la
sostenibilità aiutiamo i territori
questo è un passaggio fondamentale e
viene regolato anche dall'agenda onu
l'ultimo punto è dove si chiude
l'economia circolare cioè il design il
punto dove ha iniziato e dove finisce il
principio fondamentale che deve regolare
chi fa progettazione è quello di pensare
prima di progettare e pensare prima di
buttare via ma questo vale per le
aziende ma vale per tutti voi cosa vuol
dire vuol dire che quando io vado
a progettare devo pensare esattamente il
destino di quell'oggetto e tutte le gli
avanzi produttivi che vengono generati
pensando a un'economia circolare che
vengono ripresi e reinseriti in un
secondo ciclo se il capo finito viene
riconsiderato se sono avanzi può essere
rigenerati senza questi principi dal mio
punto di vista è in base alla mia
esperienza non possiamo parlare di
sostenibilità come fanno tante aziende
oggi sono tutti disponibili oggi sono
tutti sostenibili e tutti etici ma non è
così
è un grande bluff quindi questi sette
principi dal mio punto di vista regolano
esattamente quello che deve essere lo
sviluppo green e soprattutto quel
risparmio che voi non pagate o l'azienda
non paga sarà qualcun altro a pagarlo
per voi che è l'ambiente e il nostro
futuro
[Applauso]